JOANNA SMITH: Any
time that you can
settle for computing
a less precise answer,
you're going to get
a performance win.
I'm Joanna Smith.
And I'm going to show
you how to balance
the drive for perfection
against the need
for perfect performance
while still keeping
your users perfectly happy.
Approximation is all about
cutting corners and making
things good enough for users
and then convincing developers
that it's OK to do that.
Consider a trip planner app
that uses the user's location
to offer reminders to get
gas or suggestions on where
to eat or cool things to see.
Now the app doesn't need
the device's location
down to the foot to do this.
A zip code might
actually be all it
needs until the user
accepts a suggestion
and then asks for
navigation directions.
That would be the moment to
increase the GPS's precision.
And this is
approximation in action.
Using less time, calculating a
less precise result that still
meets the user's current need.
So how much time
is your app wasting
with a more precise result
when something less precise
would not be
noticed by the user?
Put in this slide, the potential
for savings for approximation
is everywhere.
Like with our trip planner app.
While the user is driving
on that long, long road,
it's not necessary to poll
the server for updates
exactly every five. minutes.
Instead, your app could
batch and schedule
requests less precisely and
less frequently to save battery
which the user will
need if they get a flat.
The app could also
calculate a path
between two cities
on the trip and then
use the estimated travel
time to set an alarm
for some future time when it
will wake up, turn on the GPS,
and start offering
suggestions again.
Because until there is a
point of interest nearby worth
offering to the
user, there really
isn't much use in tracking
the user's location
along that long empty highway.
And, of course, there
are approximations
as simple as
allowing your images
to be slightly lower resolution
in order to save memory space
and increase rendering speed.
Because when the
user is scrolling
through a list of potential
stops along the road,
they don't need the
fully detailed image yet.
You can load that when they're
contemplating the decor
of their chosen restaurant.
Now I'm going to say this
again, so listen this time.
For a large majority
of your code,
you don't need
100% exact results.
By demanding less
from the hardware
and still giving users
everything they need,
you can potentially gain
a lot for your frame rate
and for the device's
battery life.
So at its core, approximation
is all about tradeoffs.
Which in reality is just like
everything else in performance.
And that's why you need to check
out the rest of our Android
Performance Patterns
Content and consider
joining our G Plus community
for tips, tricks, and help.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.